freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge einen tag persönlicher koch
und der mann der hier neben ihr steht
ist der schreck von gemeinte einem
restaurant betreiber das ist nämlich der
liebe carsten carsten henn
restaurantkritiker und heute ist der tag
gekommen wo die ganzen leute die man
schreibt ja kommen wir sind doch eh alle
befreundet deshalb geben die podest
vorbei ich hab gesagt sei kritisch mit
mir
ich gebe mir heute wirklich ich gebe 110
prozent ich werde probieren alles zu
reißen was ich nur kann und ja du lieber
kasten darfst heute oder musst heute
essen ja ja ich freue mich darauf ich
habe auch einige richtig schwierige
aufgaben gestellt ja manches klingt
leichter als es wirklich ist im detail
ja was du da kann man dann auch daran
scheitert und auch wenn ich im
restaurant bestellte immer die gänge wo
die könnte scheitern
hoffen wir mal dass beim frühstück alles
gelingt es gibt suzuki joghurt mit
selbstgemachten symmetry straßen bei der
zubereitung 300 milliliter wasser 500
gramm mehl zehn gramm salz 100 gramm
geröstetem sesam kerne
ich benutze übrigens doppelnull mail typ
550 es auch super
das mixen wir mit salz zusammen lösen
zehn gramm hefe in lauwarmem wasser auf
dabei dürfte eher ruhig sehr
konzentriert gucken der schnappen uns
den knethaken für die küchenmaschine und
geben alles zusammen das lassen wir zu
etwa fünf minuten durch kneten ihr könnt
das ganze natürlich auch von hand machen
ohne küchenmaschine dann habe ich mir
nicht nehmen lassen auch selbst nochmal
hand anzulegen und durch zu kneten damit
sich die gluten struktur auch schön
aufbaut wir formen eine kleine kugel
daraus eben dem teig liebe und decken
das ganze mit plastikfolie
ach ja für 30 minuten stehen lassen
jetzt müsst ihr ein messer schärfen und
eure besten fruit ninja skills auspacken
wir schnappen uns eine frische orange
werfen sie hoch und halbieren sie damit
wir frischen orangensaft pressen können
von hand mit liebe den schenken wir ein
glas ein und geben ihnen in den
kühlschrank weiter geht's mit dem
geröstetem sesam den gehen wir in eine
auflaufform können uns eine tiefe nase
er ist auch schon unser timer
abgelaufenen geschnappten uns den teig
holen ihn aus der schüssel hinaus treten
ihn zu einer rolle damit wir besser
aufteilen können und achte in die rolle
damit wir acht gleich große stücke mit
ihr 100 gramm
dann können wir auch schon den backofen
vorheizen 250 grad bei ober unterhitze
und können anfangen unseren teil zur
single zu verarbeiten
jetzt wollen wir die teigstücke nur noch
aufeinander so dass kleine rollen
entstehen pack matt die geheime zutat by
sea mit 1 trauben sirup 1 esslöffel mehl
und 30 milliliter wasser
wir geben den pöttmes in eine schüssel
natürlich probieren wir das ganze auch
geben wasser und mehr dazu und verqueren
alles jetzt schnappen wir uns unsere
teilchen rollen sie mit den händen von
innen nach außen aus und formen dieses
limit dienten fügen wir noch mal
zusammen machen coole gangs heinz und
geben das ganze in pöttmes dann packen
wir darüber in den geröstetem sesam und
geben macht das wirklich alles alles
alles mit sesam bedeckt ist ab aufs
backblech nochmal nach vorn und dann
kann das ganze auch schon auf die
mittlere schiene in den backofen schnell
ein bisschen wasser dazu und wir kümmern
uns um dies zu job wir entfernen die
haut und schneiden das ganze in etwa 5
mm dicke scheiben
wir haken petersilie klein um was
frisches reinzubringen und für das auge
die searchteq braten wir in einem
esslöffel butter ungefähr 12 minuten von
jeder seite an damit sie farbe bekommt
dann wird es auch schon zeit für unsere
eier die gehen mir einfach dazu lassen
sie auspacken würzen das ganze geben
einen deckel drauf und hohlmeier so aus
dass das eigelb noch flüssig ist
so carsten hier sitzen wir also ich habe
mich sehr ins zeug gelegt werden selbst
gebacken bis sie mit kalamata oliven
dann natürlich zu die opel mutter also
auf youtube mit einem cappuccino und
einen hand gepressten orangensaft groß
ich habe angst vor allem was leute
kommen wird schlafen kannst erklärte ich
deine darf auch gerne sehr kritisch sein
aber dafür musste wahrscheinlich erstmal
jetzt loslegen ja also erstmal wie die
optik ist herzlich immer das erste was
ich wirklich bewährt auch das plating
sorgen keller kommt das ist sehr sehr
schön
der einzige kleine kritiken wäre wenn
peter video sollte sie hat nicht auf dem
sie mit zahlen ja das ist so dass wo man
denkt okay das klingt ein bisschen
schnell aber das ist sehr schön auch
dass sie übereinander gelegt sind das
unterschiedlich geschirmte merkt dass
der bund ihren teller das ist sehr sehr
gut gelöst ein anderer punkt ist halt
dass das teller annahmen was ist das
buch brauche ich häufig achte okay dann
richtig meist wobei ich immer gucken ob
die kellner hingucken weil das machen
andere gäste einfach nicht das wird
nicht verraten als restaurantkritiker
ach ja wenn nicht wirklich so mache aber
das ist für mich immer der erste
eindruck der sich merkel wie es soll die
produktqualität bei fish creek sogar
damit ist lange der vielleicht zu
deutlich durfte ich das durch beide ist
das riecht alles gut also petersilie
haben durchaus dass sie sich durchsetzen
können sogar gegen cottbus aber dass das
was gut aussieht auch guten bis bisschen
angebraten aus dass er die die trockene
variante gewählt und so und du hast auch
die variante gewählt mit dem mit dem
spiegel es ist schön das eigelb ist
flüssig das ja nicht total wichtig ja
das war echt ein hammer minuspunkte wird
erst jetzt hat gewählt habe auch gerade
richtig hat dass ein staat der so ein
drittel oft was ist das eigentlich habe
ich meine ich probiere die komponenten
erst eins und dann zusammen
gute software global sagte wirst du
musst du sein war das bin ich jetzt sehr
puristische nummer
auch gut von der konsistenz her jetzt
muss ich gucken dass ich das einmal so
nehme die sind eigentlich zusammen geben
müsste und dann kann man als sagen der
ganze funktioniert findet das sehr
eindrucksvoll wie die detailliert oder
run geht aber ich meine klar ist sein
job also die musste gucken was passiert
zusammen es wird jetzt noch ein bisschen
was von den von dem sie mit italien
unbedingt von ihm selbst gemachtes
klingt schon mal gut
das ist sogar noch warm dass wir ein
absoluter pluspunkt ja er hat schon
mehrere der erste eindruck ist
normalerweise wortlos aber kam einfach
zu viel wissen als essen angeht als dass
man sie nicht mitnimmt deshalb wird
jetzt die kamera aus du kannst ganz in
ruhe auf essen und sich unbeobachtet
führen und dann kommt die finale
bewertung früchte
da sind wir also du hast frühstück
genossen hoffentlich dann wenn ich jetzt
sehr gespannt auf dein fazit zum frisch
ja ich habe tatsächlich und
geschmacklich überhaupt nichts zu
meckern also die hat die wichtigen
punkte waren eingeladen dort flüssig
sein da bist du cremig sein weiß dagegen
fest die zwar gut angebraten nicht zu
viel die einzigen kritikpunkte waren
eben die optik das ist geschlossen
besser wäre das mit warmer teller
tatsächlich wichtig wäre ja es um es zu
essen da würde ich jetzt eben punktabzug
geben aber ich glaube zehn punkte ist
die höchstpunktzahl ich würde sagen für
den gang würde ich dir ab ich hatte so
angst vor der ersten werde dadurch für
ihr seid 2.8 punkte leute das ist sehr
sehr gut und es wird nicht leicht heute
das kann ich nur sagen wir gehen jetzt
zum mittag isst wir benötigen salz
backpulver und ein hähnchen vielleicht
habt ihr schon geraten es gibt
brathähnchen auf einer rahmen polenta
dann schnappen wir uns erstmal eine
geflügelschere und drehen das hähnchen
um dann schneiden wir links und rechts
am rückgrat entlang um das rückgrat zu
entfernen
das ziel von der ganzen aktion ist dass
wir das hähnchen gleich flach machen
werden
dadurch wird die brust nicht so schnell
trocken und die schänke und brust sind
gleichmäßig saftige drehen das hähnchen
zurück und machen die brust platt wie
gesagt dadurch dass das hähnchen so eine
neue form bekommt wird es gleichmäßig
saftig und durch rückgrat wickeln wir in
frischhaltefolie und legen uns schon mal
in den kühlschrank dort kommt auch
gleich unser hähnchen hin aber als
erstes benötigen wir unser salz das
streuen wir großzügig über den gesamten
vor will und im anschluss unser
backpulver auch das wird großflächig
aufgetragen mit der kombination von seis
und backpulver entziehen wir der haut
von hühnchen die feuchtigkeit und
kriegen so hoffentlich noch knusprige
ergebnisse am nächsten tag bin ich auf
meinen balkon gegangen habe frischen
rosmarin thymian oregano und majoran
geschnitten das ganze gezupft und mit
dem messer klein gehackt mit diesem
frischen fein gehackten kräutern können
wir gleich unser hähnchen würzen das
über nacht im kühlschrank lag wir holen
es raus und stecken die arme unter die
brust damit sie nicht im backofen
verbrennen dann geben wir einen
esslöffel olivenöl über das hähnchen im
anschluss die frischen kräuter passieren
diese liebevoll ein und können das ganze
auch noch mit schwarzem pfeffer würzen
dann schnappen wir alles geben es in den
backofen der auf 260 grad bei ober
unterhitze vorgeheizt ist und backen
alles für 40 minuten weiter geht es mit
der sauce zu unserem hähnchen dazu
schneiden wir das rückgrat in stücke und
braten es auf der haut an
wir schneiden eine zwiebel eine karotte
etwas staudensellerie und geben alles in
die pfanne in der das hähnchen an dreht
auf höchster stufe damit röstaromen
entstehen und dann löschen wir das ganze
auch schon ab mit einer tasse martini
und einer tasse wasser hitze reduzieren
und stehen lassen
50 gramm polenta brauchen 250 milliliter
sahne und 250 milliliter milch gegeben
beides in einen topf von flügen während
des aufkocht muskatnuss hinzu 40 minuten
sind vorbei und wir holen unser hähnchen
aus dem ofen 85 grad in der brust sind
fast ein bisschen zu viel aber es sieht
einfach sehr sehr schön ausheben das
ganze auf die arbeitsfläche und decken
ist für maximal fünf minuten mit folie
ab
hören wir auch so polenta in die sahne
und milch mischung ganz wichtig
kontinuierlich rühren also wirklich
rühren rühren rühren zum schluss kommen
noch ein esslöffel butter hinein für
unsere soße arbeiten wir nur mit der
flüssigkeit weiter und wir geben
zunächst einen schuss sojasauce und aber
auch in etwas orangensaft hinzu dann
noch drei esslöffel butter dann bleibt
uns nur noch übrig das ganze zu
verquirlen und es im anschluss schön
anzurichten
[Musik]
für das mittagessen in einem ice polenta
eine rahmen polenta proben drauf
brathähnchen und dazu ein zitronig
fleißig sauer sonst war alles möglich
die saucen etwas das würdest du sagen
wenn jemand das so beschreibt das war
wahrscheinlich die beine in die hand
nehme drauf ja das wäre nicht schlecht
aber es hört es sollte bis in die
hardware ich brauche immer noch gemeinde
nach was ist wenn es um das und wenn ich
es nicht wissen ist einfach klar wir
sind nicht ordentlich geschult okay okay
fragt hersteller ist es ist leicht
bayerischen gut duftet er ist nicht mehr
so kraus ja ich habe auf den fehler
gemacht und soße übergossen
hast du glaub ich gar nicht so stark
gewürzt ja genau das aber bewusst weil
ich glaube wenn man dann noch ein
bisschen von der soßen mit dran denkt an
wenn du jetzt so stark gewürztes ohne
hast dann gleicht sich das wieder aus
okay die hand nicht so latzel zu
überraschen
nicht mitgerechnet heftig ja kann man
machen aber mein lacht aber das
wichtigste ist jetzt ob das saftig ist
oder nicht jetzt schon mal ganz gut aus
von der optik her ja so also das geht
ganz gut auseinander
vielleicht ist ja immer die brust zu
trocken weil ich wieder schönfeld ja
aber hier darauf kommt es jetzt
tatsächlich trotz armbrust wirklich
saftig geworden ist aber es sieht es die
tatsächlich schon mal gut aus also wenn
es richtig trocken ist ein letzter schon
nicht so ohne
ich habe kleine theater - punkt du hast
irgendwie beim schneiden sie knüpfen
geschmückten ja hier ist jetzt habe ich
noch nicht so oft gemacht worden so ein
hühnchen auseinandergenommen glaube wir
machen jetzt mal wieder den braker lässt
das alles auf sich wirken macht ihr noch
mal ein gesamtbild und dann kommt hinein
bewerten daher setzen wir ich habe auch
gelesen was lecker jetzt bin ich
gespannt wie du es ja also ich bin du
hast wirklich vieles vieles richtig
gemacht habe der wichtige punkt dass die
brust nicht zu trocken wird das hast du
hast du gut gemacht ich fand die haut
sehr starke wird und vielleicht auch
taschen packen zu starten großen mankos
dabei waren jetzt zum einen eben
wirklich dass das war ja das ist
eigentlich so eine sache die sein muss
beim braten und eben dass der schnitt
anklopfen falsch war gut zusammen
gegangen sind so tipps und und polenta
und fünf oder auch schön dazu eigentlich
denkt man blättert im rat hinterthal und
aber einigen genau meine note mich nicht
nur ein bisschen runter gehen sondern
zum schutz gegen den beiden genannten
fehlern und wird bereits von 10 punkten
ja ich glaube ist aber also gemeint ist
ja dass brathähnchen das testbericht ist
ich glaube es ist okay oder also 6 19 ja
es passiert immer wieder dass den
restaurantgästen christen haben das
durchweg für meinen für mein ego wenn
ich noch mal machen und gucken ob ich
die haut besser
wir sehen uns beim abendessen kasten hat
sich von mir zum abendessen die flinken
gewünscht die absolute königsdisziplin
ihr seht schon jede menge zutaten aber
wir fangen erst mal an mit einem
wunderschönen rinderfilet davon
benötigen wir jedoch nur die mitte das
chateaubriand geht einfach darum dass es
gleich groß ist an allen seiten wiegen
das ganze ab bisschen über 700 gramm
wirklich ein prächtiges stück wir hier
sehen könnt dann entfernen wir die
silber haut und probieren dabei
natürlich so wenig wie möglich von
unserem viele zu verschwenden also ganz
vorsichtig sein dabei dann schnappen wir
uns champignons hatten die ganz ganz
fein 500 gramm champignons insgesamt
alles von hand nein wir können das ganze
natürlich auch mit einem mixer oder
einem food prozessor machen geben dass
zur seite schneiden schalotten fein
würfeln 2 knoblauchzehen fein und
dünsten schalotte und knoblauchzehen in
einer pfanne an
dann kommen die champignons drauf und
wir lassen das ganze aus kochen weil die
champignons noch jede menge wasser
abgeben wenn sie ein bisschen wasser
abgegeben haben können wir auch schon
unseren whiskey hinzufügen 30 milliliter
ein guter schluck und lassen das ganze
weiter ein kochen bis so eine paste
entsteht dann stellen wir das ganze zur
seite jetzt machen wir crêpes mit 50
gramm mehl einem und 140 millilitern
milch natürlich kommt noch eine kleine
prise salz dazu dann verkehren wir das
alles machen unsere beste burak
impression und haben einen crap teig aus
dem wir zwei drei crêpes backen in einer
mittleren fahne um später mit den crap
unser viele einrollen zu können ihr
müsst euch bei der größe der knappen
bisschen eurem viele anpassen meine sind
ein bisschen klang gewesen aber unsere
filet braten wir jetzt erstmal an dafür
lasse ich ein wenig rinderfeld auf
markus eisern platte aus und wir braten
unser viele für 30 bis 60 sekunden von
jeder seite einmal an um es dann runter
zu nehmen und direkt mit die chancen von
allen seiten zu bestreichen bzw 1 zu
massieren daraufhin legen wir auf
unserem crêpes parmaschinken aus um
einfach einen kleinen schutzfilm zu
bilden dann nehmen uns unsere dexcel
also unsere champignon passte und tragen
sie dick auf dem parmaschinken auf ein
wenig platz am rand lassen dann
schnappen wir
unser viele und können das ganze wickeln
leute ich war so angespannt wir packen
das ganze brut in frischhaltefolie ein
und lassen das komplett im kühlschrank
auskühlen für etwa eine halbe stunde
wir haben unseren blätterteig
vorbereitet packen die rolle aus der
frischhaltefolie aus und umwickeln das
ganze mit vollster konzentration mit
blätterteig wichtig wirklich dass alles
komplett geschlossen ist ihr seht ich
habe mich sehr gefreut dass es gepackt
habe um alles zu schließen den teig
einfach an den entsprechenden stellen
zusammenkneifen und wir können unser wie
vor linken mit einer mischung aus eis
und wasser bestreichen
im übrigen blätterteig habe ich noch in
streifen geschnitten in einem schönen
muster oben drüber gelegt dann habe ich
alles noch mal ganz sorgfältig
bestrichen das ist wichtig damit wir
eine gleichmäßige bräunung haben wenn
wir alles wieder aus dem backofen rollen
dann habe ich die überstehenden streifen
abgeschnitten mir eine gute handvoll
flakes heute genommen und das großzügig
auf unseren wie vor linken aufgetragen
dann war es auch schon zeit das ganze in
den ofen zu geben bei 190 grad für 40
minuten und bauleute das muss eine der
schönsten sachen sein die ich gemacht
habe
jetzt der wichtigste moment hat es eine
schöne farbe und ich bin durch ein
bisschen stolz muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagen ich habe mir ein stück geschnappt
alibi kräuter dazu getan und es carsten
serviert
[Musik]
da ist es also das bi frühling nicht auf
selten habe ich so sehr mit gefiebert
beim kochen davon irgendwas du siehst es
schon keine soße dabei das ist leider
ein projekt was auf den letzten metern
gescheitert ist ein fachmann arm war so
müde und da bin ich so mit dem stylus
ausgerutscht deshalb gibt es das jetzt
sehr puristisch für dich sehr gespannt
was du sagen ja erst mal toll dass du
die herausforderung angenommen hat mit
erst zu einer dieser ganz großen
küchenklassiker gibt es seit 1900 gibt
es das und es müssen sich alle großen
fläche irgendwann mal gemacht haben
das ist eine sensation waren die
forellen zu machen weil du weißt ja
einfach nicht wie es aussieht wenn du es
aufschreiben ja auch immer der heikle
punkt und das ist erst mal wirklich echt
schön
ja also der farbverlauf ist da du hast
es in der mitte schön rosa hinbekommen
und außen für mich auch die färbung vom
wetter heidi ist sehr schön geworden
also dieses goldbraune so muss es sein
also das ist wirklich so rein optisch
erstmal sehr sehr gut und das rind
richter
das merkt man du hast ein gutes fleisch
genommen total wichtig auf dabei und
dass man da nicht am nicht am
fleischmarkt die soße ist schade dass
ich nicht dabei sei gerade so eine
schöne mandira somit ein bisschen
trüffel
das wird dann vom landtag aufgesaugt
naja wird also ein großes schlüssiges
ganzes gleiche soße ist das was da noch
so ein bisschen ja es sind jetzt
natürlich der geschmack das klingt schon
gut also das geräusch des better teils
ist gut leitet das kleid wird wirklich
durch und gibt es auch gut durch gute
pilz gibt es gibt es variationen auch
mit gänseleber es geht um das fleisch
er hat ein tolle konsistenz geschmack
schöne saftigkeit jetzt noch mal ist
alles zusammen aber das macht einen
guten eindruck macht das ist auch die
gabel
dann heißt es auch schon wir sehen uns
zur finalen bewertungen wieder eine
wahnsinnstat leute bis gleich das war
der letzte gang das letzte essen ja ich
hatte ehrlich gesagt gedacht das packst
du total diesen großen klassiker ist wie
vor linken
du musst mir sagen ob ich wenn ich das
gericht bewerten soll dann ja durch mich
immer sagen es geht tatsächlich eine
soße wenn du sagst ich sollte nur dass
das eigentliche stück bewährten durch
heute darum mich zu kritisieren die soße
ab gefehlt kann man kann man auf jeden
fall so sagen also wenn ich dass ich nur
dass nur das stück fleisch wird das
platziert man merkt dass ein tolles
stück leicht genommen
der becher tag warmuth außenrum das
dekret war gut die faser wird er hat
sich super geschritten das war echt
schon wirklich klasse und der einzige
kleine fehler war dass es unten ein
bisschen aber das mag nicht das hat die
soße kompensiert und genau das hat die
soße kompensiert also wenn ich nur das
stück fleisch bewerten soll wo das
eigentliche training dann wärst du bei
9,5 punkten das war echt das kann man
kaum besser machen wenn ich das ganze
bewährten mustern ist natürlich die
fehlende soße dann schon schon punkt
dann muss man da runter geht als musical
oder als befriedigt übrigens eindeutig
wenn das geklärt werden müsse dann würde
ich untergehen auf 27 okay damit kann
ich leben also mit dem im hinterkopf
weil die soße war ich ein dummer fehler
von mir hätte eine passable soße auf
jeden fall hinbekommen wenn ich nicht
verzeichnete aber wirklich kassen ich
danke dir für das ganze wissen dass du
heute mit uns geteilt hast solltest du
dass du dir die zeit genommen hast etwas
ganz ganz wichtiges der kasseler nämlich
noch was mitgebracht die see ist da
vorne im kasten ist nämlich nicht nur
restaurantkritiker sondern auch autor
von weiß selbst mit ihren büchern wie
ich weiß es wirklich mich also ganz ganz
vielen kulinarischen krimis gewinnung
des essen
gutes trinken es geht um wein und whisky
und tee und kaffee käse und dass wir die
letzten beiden der sinn des lebens
stehen filme wo die älteste der welt ist
und das kommt erst am 16 juli ausruhen
oder her besteht auf jamaika wo es den
franken
untenrum gebäude spaß und premier hat
für den ist osten und vor allem auch
wenig beeindruckt wie viel über essen
weist bei das steckt ja alles hier drin
im zusammenhang mit einer spannenden
geschichte deshalb leute bei link euch
da mal was dazu in der infobox
dankeschön noch mal und wir sind zwar
nächsten video